well part of being you know athletic and
even also to having like brothers and
sisters I think it makes you more
competitive because you're used to being
in that group setting and having a vie
for attention or scoring or whatever it
is would you say you're competitive oh
absolutely yeah absolutely I hasa I
think you have to be like you said it's
healthy competition is healthy right
like I'm I'm a big fan actually and it's
a funny sort of segue but it totally
makes sense and this is why I think
identify and just love it so much but
the sport of mixed martial arts I can
I'm sure you've heard of UFC you know i
mean that's that's doesn't like the big
leagues yeah right well I've been
following them since you know like the
early 90s when it was sort of the more
barbaric version of it where was you
know a 300-pound 64 guy versus like a
five 850-pound guy like now it's
obviously way more restricted and and
and just there's more rules you know
it's it's a sport now and it's why it's
the worldwide phenomena that it is but I
love so many of the athletes and Sony
the athletes that that I follow our are
they just have a mindset about you know
they're the champions it's just
interesting to watch how they speak
about things you know there's a comfort
and a confidence about just their
persona just their way of being you know
and and and and it's like the simple
saying like powerful people don't have
to act powerful they just are you know
it's it's as simple as that like Meryl
Streep and devil wears prada perfect
example I love that because she is a
powerful person and we know that as soon
as we are introduced to her but she's
very subtle and everything she does and
then nothing is her acting at being
powerful and that's an easy thing to do
you get scripts like that all the time
where people oh I have to be tough and
have to act you know tough but it's like
if you've ever met Mike Tyson in real
life like he's the simplest calmness guy
you've ever made so scary actually like
he's nice they may not have all time to
talk to him it's but it's eerie how calm
he really is you know and we all know
him from you know from growing up and
the stories but he's a simple guy but
you know this guy can kill you you know
like and there's just something about
his comfort that you know he doesn't
have to act at that you know and I think
going back to like the UFC and just the
competitive nature like UFC's amazing
they're a great product it's you know i
right
articles and I have friends that are
fighters and stuff for that like I'm a
big advocate of the sport but they also
are the biggest fish in town and they're
almost the only fish in the pond at this
point like there are very few companies
that well there's not even any company
that I think directly competes with them
there are people that are trying to get
to a point where they can sort of
compete and I don't think that that's
good because you need competition
combating competition breeds just just
you know that that it fuels that fire
that we continue to work harder to be
better you know so I think if you're the
best at what you do and you're the only
person at what you do it really is hard
to continue to grow you know unless you
have somebody that's on your tail that
and you're like well I need to grow
because this person is almost there you
know I think it's good to have that back
and forth so I'm I'm fully competitive
by nature of of course but also um by
necessity like I feel like I need to
surround myself with people like I
always tell you know like my producing
partners like I don't want to be I don't
want us three to be the best at you know
of our you know like of our production
you know cuz we're not we're new you
know we've been lucky to produce two
films so we're not you know we're not
Harvey Weinstein like you know we're
very much beginners at what we do but I
love surrounding myself with people who
are better than me because that's then I
can rise to their levels and continue to
do that it's like sports like I never
want to be the best person on the team
you need to surround yourselves with
like a team of Michael Jordan so that
you can rise to the occasion and and
learn and get better as well like I
fully believe that you know I feel like
if you're the best person on the team
like who's challenging you you know like
you it's a team sport so you need to
continuously you know support each other
but and in supporting each other I think
that means challenging each other as
well so I love being challenged and and
being competitive with my peers because
that that feeds us and I feel like
that's gonna feed me to continuing to
you know work harder towards it you know
you don't never want to get to a point I
feel where you plateau or just don't
need to work hard you know and
and so for me competition is a very
important part of that like I watch TV I
my tan that person got the job over me
okay you know but it's good it feels it
feeds me inside and and I'll never
forget you know I and it may just simply
be I see that then a month later I'm on
an audition for something and see the
person in the room and just remembering
that I'm like okay you know we're going
in we're bringing this you know what I
mean because it's just that connection
you know so I I absolutely you know
encourage and and I don't think I'll
ever not be competitive I'm a very
competitive person for sure and i'm also
very supportive though to like i know i
feel there are a lot of people who can
be competitive but they can't also
celebrate um an accomplishment of
somebody and I don't ever want to be
that person and I have an ego and I have
you know times where i can get jealous
or envious too but like I always have
check out and try to remind myself like
don't let this be about that like it's
okay to be happy for people and you have
to be an anchor and I've even some of my
closest friends sometimes I feel like
they have a hard time showing that they
can be happy for somebody you know and I
get it you know I get that but you know
I think it's important that we just kind
of know the differences of two things
and so we can continue to support each
other you know in a good way
you